[Musique]
un lieu encore secret des portes qui
s'ouvrent un public attroupés qui
lentement s'engouffre l'inauguration de
la médiathèque cette semaine n'a pas
prennent et un équipement très attendu
par les habitués de l'ancienne
médiathèque georges brassens et de
celles encore en activité 17 mar eric
étudiants en musique première
utilisateurs de la discothèque
enfin c'est ouvert ainsi après trois
mois de fermeture de georges brassens ou
est ce juste servir 17 mars était un peu
limité alors que maintenant c'est
vraiment une grande joie à tendance
plutôt classique et rock la collection
de cd atteint 12 mille titres sans
parler des 1500 partition 700 livres de
musique et autres 700 cassette
n'oublions pas l'auditorium bien sûr et
8 postes d'écouté
voilà pour la musique et le premier
étage un petit détail cependant avec 100
francs vous pourrez profiter de ce
service toute l'année au rez-de-chaussée
la bibliothèque dont l'abonnement est
gratuit propose pour l'instant 40 mille
ouvrages du polar aux grands classiques
de littérature en passant par la presse
reste la vidéo deuxième étage sont 50
francs par an là ce sont 2500 cassette
qui sont disponibles mais aussi des
documentaires et des archives de l'ina
voilà pour les chiffres et pour donner
une idée de la masse des documents
disponibles
un dernier petit repère quand même pour
vous permettre de vous représenter la
surface occupée sur trois niveaux par le
bâtiment
elle couvre environ 5000 mètres carrés
soit la superficie d'un terrain de
football
[Musique]